an emotional debate congresswoman Ilan
Omar a refugee from Somalia and one of
the first Muslim women in the U.S House
of Representatives voted off The Foreign
Affairs committee there is this idea
that you are a suspect if you are an
immigrant or if you are from certain
parts of the world or certain skin tone
or a Muslim
it is no accident that members of the
Republican Party accused the first black
President Barack Obama of being a secret
Muslim Republicans pointed to these
tweets from years ago where she seemed
to equate atrocities carried out by the
U.S military to those committed by
groups Washington deems terrorists she
later said she did not mean to compare
them but Republicans now in the majority
moved in a party-line vote to kick her
off the committee Democrats accused
house Speaker Kevin McCarthy of payback
after Democrats stripped two Republicans
of their committee assignments in the
last Congress a charge he denied we're
not removing her from other committees
we just do not believe when it comes to
Foreign Affairs especially the
responsibility of that position around
the world with the comments that you
make
she shouldn't serve there the
Republicans who lost their assignments a
much different story representative Paul
gosar tweeted out an animated video that
appeared to show him killing
congresswoman Alexandria ocasio-cortez
who said this move was intended to
Target women of color I had a member of
the Republican
cross diamonds in this Congress don't
tell me this is about consistency
Democrats say they will appoint Omar to
a different but still powerful committee
and Omar warned Republicans that their
move will backfire I yield back Victoria
Gayton B Al Jazeera